for the eighth time since January the
11th US air strikes have hit houthi
Targets in Yemen Jets streak off the
deck of the USS Eisenhower into the
night sky over the Red Sea and this time
as with the first strikes UK planes
joined in the military action four RAF
typhoons took off from the actii airbase
in Cyprus accompanied by Voyer
tankers later blasts lit up the darkness
of Yemen's Capital sah according to the
UK and US governments eight military
locations were hit including underground
weapon storage sites these self-defense
strikes targeted missile systems and
launchers unmanned aerial and surface
vessels storage facilities fighter
aircraft helicopters and attack boats
all with the goal of further degrading
HTI the hou's ability to conduct further
attacks on ships in the Red Sea initial
reports from the Pentagon indicate that
all the targets were hit since November
houie rebels in Yemen have been
attacking shipping in the Red Sea with
hijackings drones and missiles the group
says it's supporting Hamas by striking
commercial ships they say are either
linked to Israel or are heading to
Israeli ports though many of the ships
targeted have no known Israeli
connection what the hus are doing is
unacceptable it's illegal and it's
threatening the freedom of navigation
that's why we've taken the action
alongside that action is a whole set of
measures we'll be taking including
sanctions and other
pressure the strikes are designed to
degrade the houthi military capabilities
and send a message to them and their
backers in Iran like much Western
foreign and military policy what the UK
and us are trying to do is just enough
but not too much the dangers of
escalation are on their minds David
Cameron says it's the houthis that are
making things worse the Pentagon says
its aim is to deescalate tensions and
restore stability to the Red Sea but
there's no sign yet the houthis or their
supporters are backing
down we will not be afraid of the
American Zionist air strikes we are only
afraid of
God the US air strikes are like a spray
of water for thirsty person I swear it
will not scare us or turn a hair on our
heads and the houthis have vowed to
retaliate for these latest strikes Rory
chalins Al jazer
London make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer